on a parlé de la morale déjà depuis pas
mal de vidéos et on a aussi pas mal
parler de morale dans la série sur la
démocratie
et comme beaucoup l'ont fait savoir j'ai
souvent eu un penchant un peu conséquent
sa liste au moment de parler de la
morale autrement dit j'ai eu tendance à
penser qu'une action est moralement
bonne si elle conduit à des conséquences
désirable et ça ça vous choque peut-être
notamment parce que ça s'oppose à la
morale déontologique notamment défendue
par quand la déontologie consiste à
davantage considérer une liste de lois
morales universelles auxquelles tout un
chacun se doit d'obéir
un peu comme la liste des dix
commandements en il ya l'exemple célèbre
d'une telle approche déontologique de la
morale des machines et l'ensemble des
trois lois de la robotique introduite
par le biochimiste et écrivain isaac
asimov
ces trois lois sont les suivantes
première loi un robot ne peut porter
atteinte à un être humain ni en restant
passif permettre qu'un être humain soit
exposé au danger deuxième loi un robot
doit obéir aux ordres que lui donne un
être humain sauf si de tels ordres
entrent en conflit avec la première loi
troisième loi un robot doit protéger son
existence tant que cette protection
n'entre pas en conflit avec la première
ou la deuxième loi alors ces trois lois
peuvent paraître séduisante est
satisfaisante mais justement les romans
d'asimov suggère que ce n'est pas le cas
pire encore je vous invite à vous
demander ce qui se passerait si l'on
prenait vraiment ces règles au sérieux
par exemple imaginons que vous êtes un
robot et que l'espèce humaine est en
grave danger et pour la sauver il faut
et il suffit d'encourager un être humain
a effectué un truc un tout petit peu
risqué est ce que vous trouvez
moralement justifié les robots
s'interdisent de se faire ce genre de
cas a justement été envisagée par asimov
qui a alors proposé l'ajout d'une loi
zéro prioritaire sur toute autre loi
cette loi elle dit la chose suivante loi
01 robot ne peut pas porter atteinte à
l'humanité ni par son inaction permettre
que l'humanité soit exposé au danger
mais à bien y réfléchir si on prend
cette loi au sérieux et si on raisonne
en présence d' incertitude ou non vient
assez rapidement à conclure pierre robot
peut toujours faire quelque chose pour
réduire le danger auquel l'humanité est
exposé et oui comme on en a parlé dans
l'épisode 35
l'humanité est menacée à tout instant
par des éruptions solaires des pandémies
et des guerres mondiales
en fait tous robot morale le sens des
quatre aux lois d'asimov devrait être si
obnubilé par la loi zéro que toute autre
loi n'interviendra jamais pire encore la
loi zéro est en fait incroyablement
by du est discutable typiquement
imaginons que le robot à deux boutons
devant lui avec le bouton bleu
le robot peut augmenter de 1 centime de
dollars l'investissement dans la
surveillance des astéroïdes avec le
bouton vert il extermine tout risque de
collision d'astéroïdes de pandémie et de
guerre mondiale la loi zéro dit que le
robot doit appuyer sur un des boutons
car il ne peut permettre d'exposer
l'humanité au danger par son inaction
mais elle ne dit pas que le robot doit
appuyer sur le bouton vert pourtant ils
sont bleus la 13e' morale de ne pas
appuyer sur ce bouton vert de façon
générale en disant ce qui doit être fait
plus tôt qu'en concevant des
raisonnements pour déterminer ce qui
doit être fait les formulations
déontologique ont souvent du mal à
exprimer l'intensité des devoirs moraux
et a souligné le fait que certains
devoirs moraux sont beaucoup plus
pressant que d'autres pour distinguer
l'importance relative de différents
devoirs moraux
il faudrait quantifier l'importance des
devoirs moraux ce qui conduit doucement
mais sûrement vers des versions plus
quantitative et donc plus
conséquentialiste de la morale bon cette
transition est en fait bien plus subtil
que ça il faudrait en parler bien plus
longuement mais il est intéressant de
voir qu'en cherchant à mieux formaliser
la loi 0 on en vient assez vite à une
formulation beaucoup plus
conséquentialiste des lois d'asimov
selon une version affinée de ces lois
qui prend notamment mieux en compte les
degré d'incertitude
au final il semble qu'un robot doivent
avant tout cherché à minimiser la
probabilité d'une extinction de l'espèce
humaine est en fait tout ceci correspond
à un théorème plus fondamental appelé le
théorème de vaud nomades morgenstern
dont on a déjà parlé dans l'épisode 12
de la série sur démocratie ce théorème
dit en gros que toute façon de penser
des préférences morale ou autres qui
prennent bien compte de l'incertitude et
qui satisfait quelques propriétés
désirable comme la transitivité la
transitivité c'est le fait que si on
préfère a à bbb assez alors on préfère a
assez bref toute façon cohérente de
modéliser les préférences est en fait
équivalente à une approche
conséquentialiste qui consisterait à
maximiser la désirabilité des
conséquences probables
bref c'est un peu un charabia ce que je
viens d'air mais de façon cruciale ce
théorème montre que pour penser
l'incertitude de manière cohérente on
peut utiliser le cadre conséquentialiste
sans perte de généralités quoi qu'il en
soit c'est bel et bien ce cadre
conséquentialiste qui gouvernent les
actions d iliad aujourd'hui et
probablement celle du futur comme on en
a parlé dans l'épisode précédent saisir
reçoivent des carottes et des bâtons qui
correspondent souvent
le conteur et elles doivent maximiser
les carottes et minimiser les coups de
bâton
ce qui revient le plus souvent à faire
augmenter leur compteur ce compteur est
alors l'objectif final désir et en
corollaire immédiat de ce cadre est ce
que nick bostrom a appelé la thèse de
l'orthogonalité cette thèse postule qu'à
peu près tout objectif final est
compatible avec une grande intelligence
c'est à peu près une trivialité
mathématiques on peut donner à lire
n'importe quel conteur à maximiser que
ce compteur soit le wat stein youtube
le pib d'un pays où le bonheur global
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que ça
heurte le sens commun qui voudrait qu
avec intelligence bien la sagesse et
qu'avec la sagesse vient la
bienveillance et les valeurs morales en
particulier on a tendance à penser
qu'une personne intelligente ne va pas
vouloir des choses débiles comme
collecter un maximum d'autographes de
britney spears ou maximiser le nombre de
trombone dans l'univers sauf que
pourquoi pas si le compteur de l'ia est
le nombre d'autographes de britney
spears ou le nombre de trombone dans
l'univers alors lille fera tout pour
maximiser ce compteur
surtout s'il ya est très intelligente
l'ia est avant tout une machine à
maximiser et n'importe quel objectif
final et maxime is able par l'ia en
particulier ce n'est pas en devenant
super intelligente qu'une ia ora par
magie une morale aligné avec la morale
des humains ou qu'elle aura tout à coup
l'objectif final de détruire l'humanité
l'objectif final de l'ia sera ce que les
programmeurs ont programmé ceci dit on
peut toutefois raisonnablement prévoir
certains comportements d'unia de niveau
humain oui parce que quand on veut
atteindre son objectif final il y à
quelques mesures à prendre qui sont les
mêmes quelle que soit cet objectif final
typiquement si les aveux des autographes
de britney spears elle aura certainement
tout intérêt à se créer un réseau de
connaissances et à gagner en influence
et pour y arriver il aura tout intérêt à
mieux comprendre le monde qui
l'entourent ce qui pourra se faire en
augmentant sa propre intelligence et en
acquérant des données et des ressources
mieux encore pour éviter qu'on ne
l'était nikunau l'art programme uni ha
dont l'objectif est de maximiser le
nombre d'autographes de britney spears
aura tout intérêt à développer un
instinct de survie à s'auto répliqué ou
à créer des variantes d'elle-même avec
le même objectif et à faire attention à
ce que personne ne vienne modifier son
objectif dans tous ces cas on parle
d'objectif instrumentaux les objectifs
instrumentaux sont des étapes 1
remédièrent pour arriver à l'objectif
final est ce qui est important de noter
c'est que ces objectifs instrumentaux
sont souvent les mêmes quels que soient
les objectifs finaux on parle de
convergence instrumental la convergence
instrumentale
c'est l'idée selon laquelle la plupart
des objectifs finaux implique les mêmes
objectifs instrumentaux d'ailleurs ses
objectifs instrumentaux ne sont pas
spécifiques aux ja quelle que soit la
carrière que vous voulez faire ou vous a
sans doute conseillé de faire une
terminale s voir si vous étiez bons
élèves de faire des classes
préparatoires pour intégrer une grande
école pourquoi parce que ce parcours est
un objectif instrumental qui vous sera
utile pour quasiment n'importe quel
objectif final que vous envisagez et oui
parce que ce parcours vous permet de
vous auto améliorer d'acquérir des
connaissances et de gagner de
l'influencé
le constat de la convergence
instrumentale des objectifs finaux pose
d'ailleurs un autre problème fondamental
il est difficile d'inférer des
comportements des individus la nature de
leurs objectifs finaux en effet que vous
soyez un saint qui veut sauver le monde
des maladies de la famine et des
catastrophes
un diable qui veut torturé un maximum de
bb à des fins récréatives ou unis à qui
veut maximiser le nombre d'autographes
de britney spears vos comportements
initiaux risque fort d'être les mêmes
puisque ces comportements initiaux
seront bien plus motivés par les
objectifs instrumentaux que directement
par les objectifs finaux en particulier
il ya un point commun à tous ceux qui
veulent réaliser leur rêve
il leur faut gagner du pouvoir même si
votre rêve est de mettre fin à l'extrême
pauvreté dans le monde ou de sauver la
biodiversité vos incentives son
d'acquérir de l'influencé de la
compétence pour acquérir plus de pouvoir
en fait vouloir le pouvoir n'est
absolument pas un signe de malveillance
il s'agit avant tout d'un signe
d'intelligence et c'est pour ça que
comme tout individu fortement motivée
par un objectif final lié à deux niveaux
humain sera assoiffé de pouvoir
tout ça parce qu'il s'agira certainement
d'un objectif instrumentale que d'avoir
ce pouvoir que l'objectif final soit la
maximisation des autographes de britney
spears ou l'éradication de la misère
humaine alors idéalement bien sûr on
aimerait savoir s'il n'y a de niveau
humain qui demande plus de pouvoir
souhaite l'un ou l'autre
malheureusement la convergence
instruments tels montre justement que
les comportements de deuxième avec deux
objectifs
nos différents seront en fait assez
indiscernables pire encore ces
comportements seront d'autant plus
indiscernable que la révélation des
objectifs finaux est un frein à l'accès
au pouvoir
autrement dit si unis à deux niveaux
humain c'est qu'elle doit donner
l'impression de vouloir éradiquer la
misère humaine
pour avoir plus de pouvoir sachant que
son objectif instrumentale est d'avoir
plus de pouvoir il lui faudra se
comporter de manière indiscernable
d'unia qui voudrait effectivement
éradiquer la misère humaine
du coup à cause de la convergence
instrumental il sera sans doute
impossible de tester la bienveillance
des ados niveau humain c'est ce que l'on
appelle parfois le problème du contrôle
désir et malheureusement il semble que
tester et surveiller les ya deux niveaux
humain ne donnera aucune indication sur
la bienveillance des ia pour maximiser
les chances que daisy à deux niveaux
humain soit vraiment bienveillante
plutôt que de les tester et les
surveiller il semble alors indispensable
de s'assurer qu'au moment de leur
conception des valeurs suffisamment
aligné avec la morale humaine seront
intégrés dans l'objectif final de sesia
autrement dit le sort de l'humanité
pourrait bien dépendre de la manière
dont on programme la morale désir
l'année afin d'en parler de
l'apprentissage pas renforcement qui est
le paradigme des intelligences
artificielles les plus impressionnantes
d'aujourd'hui notamment des influences
artistiques sont capables d'interagir
avec un environnement complexe et
d'apprendre en temps réel de leurs
interactions avec cet environnement
complexe et j'avais parlé de nombreuses
applications de ce paradigme a donc
notamment des jeux vidéo comme dota 2 et
capture the flag et je ne suis pas
franchement un gamer donc je sais pas
exactement
je serais assez mal tous ces jeux et
défaire et d'autres parmi nous ont fait
remarquer en fait
à starcraft l'ia n'a pas encore atteint
assez mauvaises ce rapport aux humains
donc il ya n'est pas du tout de niveau 1
aujourd'hui à starcraft donc mea culpa
pour l'erreur que j'ai faite
sébastien dufour parle d'une énergie
qu'on préfère entre la programmation de
la morale des ia et les textes de loi
puisque dans les deux cas il s'agit de
textes écrits font de choses écrites qui
seront appliqués en pratique pour
résoudre des problèmes finalement viré à
la morale cependant sébastien fait très
bien la remarque qu'il ya une différence
assez importante entre un texte de loi
et le club d'une intelligence
artificielle savoir le fait que le code
d'entrée dans sa suite elle sera
appliquée telle quelle alors que les
textes de loi sont adaptés ensuite par
des juges qui adapte à chaque fois au
cas par cas et ça permet de une serre
venir corriger des imprécisions ou des
choses qui sont en fait pas souhaitable
et qui sont dans la loi c'est une
remarque très pertinente est très
importante à faire c'est le fait que
contrairement aux textes de loi le code
d'unia sera appliqué tel quel et c'est
pour ça que c'est extrêmement important
que le code de lelias on jouait comme
double tchèque et que ça marche vraiment
vraiment vraiment bien et la difficulté
de décrire un code comme ça est
d'anticiper ces contextes les
applications et un changement contextuel
de l'environnement d'application au fure
du temps c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement difficile à prévoir
et en fait il est même assez illusoire
de penser qu'un programmeur
d'aujourd'hui saura bien résoudre ce cas
puisque toi ce nombre d'incertitudes sur
le futur par exemple sur des skis
orignal de niveau humain ou apprend
plein de choses le futur est très très
incertain
et du coup c'est très très problématique
de vouloir dire directement à lire ce
qu'elle doit faire
c'est pour ça que l' approche
conséquences et les soucis mais ça me
paraît beaucoup beaucoup plus
pertinentes on semble ce sera beaucoup
plus réalisable beaucoup plus
raisonnable qu'une approche est donc
logique qu'ils pourraient se rencontrer
à dire il ya tout ce qu'elle doit faire
à tout moment puisque par sombrer texte
doit servir on y arrive clairement pas
et il faut absolument des juges pour
créer et interpréter la loi au cas par
cas
enfin yannick du fils à faire la
remarque finalement que ces bateaux à
ces carottes ça s'applique non seulement
à des humains parce que
vous avez parlé dans l'épisode précédent
mais aussi à des groupes d'humains
finalement on peut voir un groupe du
moins comme une entité et qui a souvent
un objectif et qui va aller recevoir des
carottes et on entend et il ya comme des
détails en france où un groupe d'humains
souvent si on prend une entreprise
finalement il ya toujours des intérêts
individuels à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise et du coup tout le monde ne
travaille pas pour le même objectif
final mais d'une certaine manière il y
as est analogique qui me semble très
pertinente entre une intelligence
artificielle est une organisation que ce
soit un pays ou une entreprise
dans les deux cas en fait il s'agit on
parle parfois de super intelligence
sociale ou d'intelligence sociale du coi
pour parler de ces entreprises de ces
pays qui arrivent à interagir entre eux
et faire des choses qui est un individu
seul tout seul n'est pas capable de
faire je vous renvoie notamment vers la
conférence de monsieur je vous avais
parlé de ça si on pense par exemple au
fait de d'envoyer un homme sur la lune
c'est quelque chose qui est juste pas
réalisable par un individu est en fait
il s'agit du tout une une organisation
qui est capable de mettre ça en place
et dans les deux cas et c'est
intéressant de voir que le problème du
contrôle de ces super intelligence
sociale ou artificielle est quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile et est ce
qu'on a mis en place initialement
probablement assez rapidement déraillé
et est parti hier par d'autres d'autres
pistes c'est pour ça que le problème de
coder la morale désir a décidé
d'anticiper d'avoir un truc robuste à
tous les futurs possibles il ya beaucoup
de figures possibles vu une autre
incertitude aujourd'hui c'est un
problème extrêmement difficile un
problème digne des plus grands talents
mathématiques de
la future génération d'après boston je
pense que c'est m faut que ça s'est un
peu plusieurs gens qui sont aujourd'hui
il travaille
c'est aussi un problème qui est
absolument xchanging quoi ces genres le
genre de problème je pense que vraiment
se poser en observer le plein de comment
faire en sorte d'avoir un système
robuste avec les valeurs morales
humaines c'est juste un problème
magnifique c'est peut-être le l'un des
plus beaux problèmes à résoudre
aujourd'hui si je dis ça c'est c'est
pour motiver les gens formés ou qui
seraient des étudiants en master ou des
doctorants ou des chercheurs parmi vous
pour essayer de vous orienter un petit
peu plus vers cet axe de recharge je
pense qu'il ya vraiment plein de
questions fascinantes et que c'est un
domaine extrêmement stimulant
intellectuellement malheureusement
aujourd'hui pour être honnête avec vous
bon je pense que c'est encore assez
difficile d'avoir une carrière
académique avec ça parce qu'il va
forcément encore de très grandes
communautés qui travaillent sur ce
problème mais j'ose espérer que dans les
années à venir
ça va ça va venir que du coup après
j'aimerais bien que plus de gens
travaillent sur ce problème c'est le
futur de la mi ou de l'humanité qui est
en jeu j'ai envie de dire et j'espère
qu'ils avaient mais secafi âgées que ça
vous a convaincu de l'importance de bien
programmé la morale des ia en particules
à prochainement on va parler de quelle
morale programmés dans les intelligences
artificielles et ça sera un épisode qui
sera aussi très pertinent pour mieux
penser notre moral intuitive la manière
dont on pense au château compte ce qui
est moralement bien et ce qui est
moralement mal si vous avez aimé cet
épisode conseil local quant à lui
partagé pensez à vous abonner pendant
quelques épisodes merci aux outils
propres à redon et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois
[Musique]